now there are lots of other applications
so for example you can record all sorts
of asset ownership on the blockchain
yeah in fact there's a
uh
something called the
ethereum improvement proposal number 821
which actually talks about how to manage
assets on the blockchain so for example
you can put
you know domains that you own so if you
own cnn.com you can record that on a
blockchain this is for digital assets if
you own stocks you can record that on a
blockchain why would you want to record
stock ownership on a blockchain well for
example if you want to deal with
voting voting rights for for stocks uh
often there's a problem with
understanding who is allowed to vote on
a particular
stock vote stock election
well if the blockchain records exactly
who owns white stock maybe it's not so
difficult to actually collect votes
appropriately
you can imagine
even for us at the university we're
thinking of putting stanford transcripts
on the blockchain so the interesting
thing there is an employer who wants to
look at the potential employees
transcripts can verify that the
transcript that he was handed to
by the employee
actually is the latest version of the
transcript yeah so the blockchain will
record at any given time what the latest
version of that student's transcript is
um and any because the blockchain is
public an employer can verify that he's
looking at the latest version of the
transcript or any other legal document
for that matter and we already talked
about uh maintaining kitties on the
blockchain yeah
uh physical assets could also be tracked
on the blockchain so for example if you
buy a work of art well there's a it's a
one-of-a-kind work of art it's kind of
interesting if you record the work of
arc art on the blockchain you can
basically have the entire provenance
chain of the work of art to see exactly
how it was transferred from owner to
owner and that's all recorded on a
blockchain so you can't so forgeries
become much much much harder yeah if
someone wants to prove to you that they
own that particular work of art they
have to use the secret key that
corresponds to that work of art to prove
to you that they own that work of art
similarly you can imagine car vehicle
identification numbers carvings instead
of storing everything at the dmv who
knows maybe the dmv loses some
information maybe they inappropriately
transfer one car uh from one owner to
another well instead all that can be
stored on the blockchain
and anyone can verify who owns which car
and it's easy to prove uh car ownership
as well now to be honest these are more
speculative applications of the
blockchain there are projects that are
trying to build these things but um
time will tell whether this is in fact a
successful use of the blockchain or not
regardless if you want to implement uh
asset management management in a
blockchain essentially what gets written
to the blockchain is a transaction that
says you know asset type say work of art
asset id you know the particular uh work
of art we're talking about and here's
the address
the hash of the public key of the owner
so if the owner wants to prove that they
really own that work of art all they
have to do is prove that they know the
secret key corresponding to this public
key okay so that's basically how this
would work so again you always have to
ask why do we want to put assets on the
blockchain i kind of explained that that
essentially
asset transfers can only happen with the
owner permission the secret key is
needed for every single asset transfer
it's easy to prove ownership in
authenticity claims
simply i just proved that i know the
secret key corresponding to the current
public key recorded on the blockchain
and then the interesting thing is
provenance and authenticity are all
recorded on the blockchain so it's
easier to tell that you're not looking
at a forgery
this might equally be applicable to uh
you know potentially pharmaceuticals and
and um and other other uh domains and so
on so there's a lot of interest in
managing assets on the blockchain but as
i said time will tell whether this is
this is a real killer app for the chain
okay good so this gives you kind of an
idea for applications for the blockchain
outside of cryptocurrencies
now that we understand that um we said
that everything is public which could be
problematic in some situations so the
next thing we're going to look at is
basically how we do privacy on the
blockchain